hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to markiplier the rage game
No Pants edition I don't know what that
means but this game was made by a guy by
the name of Gavin McLean if those words
made sense and this is static right now
because warning there are a lot of
flashing colors apparently so if you're
prone to seizures please watch with
caution or don't watch it all here we go
so the objective is you've got to throw
bombs back off the screen I didn't play
much but I just got enough to be
familiar with the stuff hello
that is ok hey ok they blow up like that
and I will kill you in in the super
speed does not help me at all because I
think ok ok there and oh those are big
bombs ok tell me that you're gonna start
throwing a big bombs my way well I
didn't know okay alright super how does
how does Super Jump help me whoa I am
the most graceful ballerina so this was
a fan made game if you couldn't tell
totally free and actually good all right
you threw me back dynamite I did not
want that exchange gotta look good we
got a crazy town am i living in what am
I here what do people think I do in my
spare time oh boy
okay so the dynoed is dangerous because
it's cluster bomb oh my god ah goddamn
this is goddamn terrifying okay okay I
think my super PAC thickness what is
that why is there a firecracker
aah oh god I can't keep track of
everything on the screen at once this is
why there was a warning everybody
oh okay so those are just extra big
explosions I guess oh boy okay
can I just pull up out of nowhere all
right let's back up a step because I
have no goddamn idea what I'm dealing
with here calm down actually I don't
think there's a rhyme or reason to it I
think I just got a plate until I gotta
throw the bombs away this is actually
really fun I'm not even lying ISM this
is this is a really cool little game
I've never played anything like it
before so I can say that it's kind of
original at least for me I'm kind of a
reverse bomberman situation going on
always perpetually about to blow myself
off that does not help me I don't know
where the rage game part comes in I'm
actually having a the time of my life
blowing this ball damn bombs back hey I
gotta make sure that Oh actually
startled me alright try this again I
wanna get back into the really deep
layers of the music okay if I could just
the controls aren't exactly perfect
guessing jump throwing help me in some
fashion I have no idea you yeah what's
he got now you got nothing that didn't
do a damn thing Otto's dead why
Oh God apparently I'm terrible at this
game I would make a lot of sense my
first attempt is gonna be my best I'm
never ever ever ever ever
we're gonna match up to it I can do this
I can do this boat wait well we will
ah took Hoshi he'll Bob get out here no
you're not wanted
crew I don't know if the jump throw
actually does help but I'm gonna do it
just cuz it feels good
I need to spread my legs all the way up
in the air huh yeah oh why you can burn
me well I didn't do anything okay okay
things are getting a little crazy here
good thing you have immortality because
then I don't have to pay attention let's
go over the big points oh no no no no no
no no no no no oh god I can't see
everything's going crazy other Oh
not what I wanted I hit the start button
I hit the floor but you didn't do it I
hit the throw button I had one more time
cuz this is actually fun hey don't throw
that back on a also am i under the
assumption that it's my fans that are
throwing bombs at me cuz they love me so
much oh boy oh no you don't I know I
have more time than that by dawn and I
go whoa super jump which is so super
useful cuz I don't even want to try
jumping over an explosion no get out of
my hands
god damn you didn't want to get out of
my hands but again this one ha get out
of here oh I'm alive
no no no goddamn it no no how come for
sure I was damn dead oh my god it's like
the bombs can self-other Buster gray
mortality thank you thank you very much
okay I didn't do anything
okay so the big bombs are worth 25
points
the little bombs are worth 10 these
firecrackers are worth a lot of points
oh god oh god oh god oh god okay okay
let's just calm down I can't even get
one bomb oh I see the firecrackers they
go oh look at her
Oh goddamn it now Oh give me a big one
oh oh it's so terrifying just a sec god
damn
I think it's fully intended by the
developer for me to say that this is
hard
oh god this is harder than it looks
that's what she said
goddamn when is that joking a retire
yeah it's really hard to be accurate
about exactly where I am in 3d space cuz
like a full 3d 2d platformer I gotta get
as many points in the beginning as
possible I gotta stop stop me oh who is
oh that wasn't invincible that was Joe
why did they give me the useless ones
whoa wait whoa oh yeah I knew that was
gonna happen cuz it was gonna blow off
the one next to it not today yeah
not today not today what does that hold
it super throw good go for me oh you
come down there Bessie I'm sweating
already
this is like really stressful haha but
I'm doing it I'm doing it cuz that
midair guys whoa well that was bad
okay give me that give me that whoa hey
whoa hey look I know what I want to know
what I wanted oh god I don't want that
that was that lose that jump a super
jump I'll take it
I'll take super dope okay okay
oh it comes raining back down how is
that fair
y'all not fair not fair not fair give me
that give me some give me a goddamn
thing
Oh whoa Nelly Nilla oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh boy oh boy what is that
a clear on
oh it's fire why is there fire oh oh my
god no I was doing so good I'll do so
good what words that God this really fun
I'm not gonna live it's like this like
one of those games that you know is
unbelievably addictive just because it's
fun and repeatable and quick and the
punishment is severe and I want to see
the end even though there isn't an end I
want to see what other monstrosity sicán
send my way
I thought it was gonna blow up a big one
I thought I was gonna be dead let me
just talk about my strategy while I
playing this throwing bombs back while
I'm not wearing pants I just want to say
I noticed that before didn't say
anything about it because it's normally
how I play games especially right now
ohh sweating at the store I am being
very too serious about this but I want
to win so what Silver's rages on Ellie
so his people get me super-dead come on
oh this so difficult Sagat okay screw
you oh okay
Oh that'll do Pig oh yeah this is all
the commentary on this is just a blind
panic from sir I threw it back in okay
immortality' over oh god oh god oh
jelly beans I don't know if it's gonna
like carry me off into the distance if
I'm holding a firecracker at the same
time as it goes cuddle away oh my
goodness gravy oh my goodness are they
gonna kill they
God why oh god oh god okay you hear oh I
thought I saw gone oh I'm so gone that's
a repeat
score on the outskirts new personal
bests okay Oh Stan's gonna give me a
goddamn heart attack okay so that is
markiplier the rage game if you guys
want to play it for yourself there's a
link down the description right there
totally free let me know what your high
score is if you manage to be 12:55 I'll
be very impressed
I believe it's totally possible I only
play this for about 15 minutes here so
just thank you all so much for watching
thank you Gavin McLean for making this
game for me check out other awesome
games that people have made for me in
the past in the description below or
through the annotation over there thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you
in the next video oh god it's turning
back Jim Oh a little bit no no come over
there over there over there
Oh daddy box - okay Google hello hey
how's it going
ah-ha oops my mistake